[Music]
[Applause]
so it's the highest you've ever slept at
almost a while when you don't have a
fear of heights it's not really scary
it's like being in the craziest free
house that you can possibly imagine
that's Marc's in it he's a professional
rock climber and he's talking about
sleeping in a tent
they're called total edges that's
hanging off the side of a mountain he's
been climbing for over 30 years and his
favorite walls to climb are really
really high alpine big wall climbing is
the pursuit of scaling the biggest
cliffs on planet Earth oh yes they take
a few days to summit so he has to camp
out along the way so I want to know what
does it feel like to sleep in a
portaledge hanging off the side of a
mountain the one thing that's more or
less ever-present in the mountains is
wind it can be pretty violent you can
experience hurricane-force winds there's
also this thing that we call the Bronco
ride wind comes in hits a question it
really has nowhere to go except for up
eventually it hits you and your latch
and it can lift the whole thing up so
you can be suspended and then of course
the ledge that slams into the wall
you're just thinking about surviving and
that wasn't the worst of it
the smell in the ledges is not it's not
nice you don't change your clothes you
don't bathe it's wicked scummy but
people love it they continue to climb
and explore do all of this punishment
because there's still that one question
left how does it feel the way it makes
you feel is like a tiny speck of dust
very empowering it really is just like
kind of the most spectacular spot that
you could be on planet Earth
[Music]
[Music]
the tigre region in northern ethiopia is
known for its assembly of rock hewn
churches
[Music]
sculpted out of sandstone the most
wondrous of these is abouna Yamazaki
[Music]
there's only one way up you have to
climb this cliff face welcome to the
world's most perilous Church
[Music]
established in the fifth century the
church is named after its founder and
builder Father Yamada perched 650 feet
above a steep cliff some say he chose
its location to be closer to heavenly
spirits
others argue it was a strategic move to
avoid his enemies either way the
church's location ceiling frescoes and
precious goatskin Bible have attracted
worshipers for centuries the church has
20 clergymen and is managed by this
high-ranking priests he has lived here
for over 47 years and he makes the climb
every day I know MA she would offer it
as I said ie behind how do you say
Christianity you know yeah a girl garlic
- see what - yeah he didn't match their
muscle guys mr. Gotti quaintest on what
whoo yeah you could lose it in mousey
yeah
[Music]
for fearless worshipers the two-hour
track to the top begins by hiking to the
bottom of the rock from the valley below
visitors must first remove their shoes
before climbing
Misato medieval hollow for him oh come
the Southfield Muslim the Harrigan ha ha
Ozzy has the reversal noggin satellite
Italian it was who are you Lucy
Cillian and random aimless in which we
learn and hundred of the final obstacle
to the church's entrance can test the
most ardent pilgrims faith
a narrow cliff ledge with a deadly drop
to the left and no room for error
[Music]
once through you may think you're in
heaven but you've never felt more alive
who the hell are you a Christian Z Z is
a greedy Asiata Christianity they
selling me yen then the next day I had
highly citizen a you to Honolulu I was
equating you I made a higher horn longer
than the seniority
[Music]
while canyoneering is a brand-new sport
it starts with an old-school leap of
faith its participants hold their breath
as they repel down seemingly bottomless
canyons formed by centuries of wind and
water through oncoming waterfalls around
blind turns and dangling over cliffs the
sports pioneers take on natural wonders
the rest of us would never dare KITT
Turner is one of those pioneers he and
his team are about to enter Canada's box
canyon for the first time a place that
will make their knees quake I got
started running canyons in Hawaii I
started rock climbing and eventually
made the progression into Canyon area
then as my girlfriend she's a Hawaii
girl born and raised we've been dating
now for almost two years we went
climbing kid always pushes me to go it's
on me comfort level the line
when you're talking about canyoneering
the process of descending a canyon you
have to decide how much rope you want to
bring along you want to decide if the
rock quality is gonna be good enough to
set up anchors for the repels you also
have to find a good crew that is good
under pressure you're just dealing with
lots of complexities of nature rocks
waterfall it's just constant problem
solving using your brain using your body
canyons are very fickle and they're very
weather dependent conditions in a canyon
can change from one day to the next from
one season to the next
for this particular Canyon box canyon
you have to across the Squamish river
kayaking across the river it was an
ordeal because you just really have to
paddle your heart out just to cut across
that current and then you have to make a
sharp you turn into this little tiny
beach front so once you cross the river
there's a mosquito-infested hike into
kind of the bottom of the box canyon
stream and then you hike upstream for a
while before you get to the technical
part of the canyon which involves rope
the first thought was is this man-made
this is not real it looks like a
Disneyland ride
box canyon is considered a Class C
Canyon
most of the repels if not all the repels
are going straight through the
watercourse which is straight through
the waterfall and you're you're getting
pounded by the water it's hitting you in
your face you're slipping you're sliding
all over the place my favorite thing
about dropping into a canyon is the rush
of getting over the edge this is my
passion man like I get more puffs come
in a canyon it kind of adds that element
of excitement where you can't see where
you're gonna end up when you're on the
edge as an adventurer when you feel like
I could die doing this right now but I
can't back down and then you do it it's
like the most amazing feeling
I don't get the people that are like why
would you do that I'm just like why not
if you don't get it you don't get it for
someone who's looking at doing what we
did which is dropping everything and
pursuing their dreams I would say that
it's definitely a leap of faith and
maybe you crash and burn but the highs
are incredible and you're never gonna
get those amazing moments and see if you
can really achieve your dreams if you
don't try
[Music]
[Music]
located in past onea Slovenia is a
sturdy castle built into a natural
cavern halfway up a four hundred foot
cliff side pred yama castle was built in
the 13th century in Gothic style
architecture however after a siege in
the 16th century the exterior was
reconstructed and is what you see today
but there's more to this castle than
meets the eye
beneath it blaze the post onea cave park
the caves are accessible during May to
September and closed in the winter so as
not to disturb the hibernating local
bats the castle has changed ownership
throughout its history however the most
famous inhabit are was Ezra Luger he was
a 15th century Robin hood-like character
who stole from the rich to give to the
needy today the castling caves are open
for the public to explore and learn more
about its previous colorful owners
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you're looking at some platforms
usually it's just water everywhere
which makes you feel really really tiny
jumping into this giant ocean
I'm Rachelle Simpson and I'm a world
champion cliff diver it's very similar
to Olympic diving the only difference is
at the end we're going to land on our
feet as I climb up on the platform's
easier the wind blowing your ears
sometimes there's seagulls zooming
around my head hear the announcer call
my name it's kind of like I'm going into
this hallway and this sounds totally
cutting out because that's when I'm
going into focus nice when I set my feet
and then my arms go up I count to three
and go your bodies on autopilot and your
brain is just sitting back watching
front somersault twist second somersault
right position actually when you hit the
water at first you don't notice anything
and then it starts all coming back you
create bubbles underneath the surface
and you feel those bubbles pushing you
back up to the surface credit cool
feeling actually can we come up take a
breath the air and the rush of
adrenaline it's like you've been holding
it off and not even breathing until you
hit that water each time I enter the
water
it's another successful moment of
convincing my brain to be something I'm
scared of but each time I get a sense of
empowerment when I overcome it I love it
you
[Applause]